The US Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention,
otherwise known as the CDC,
has faced some major criticisms during the pandemic,
ultimately highlighting that
the public health agency
failed to meet the
world's expectations.
So in an effort to learn
from past mistakes,
its director has
initiated an overhaul
meant to revamp everything
from the agency's operations
to its culture.
I flew down to its
headquarters in Atlanta
to ask CDC Director
Rochelle Walensky
how the revamp is going.
When you first announced Moving Forward,
you laid out your vision
for the agency and how
it must evolve and here
you said that the agency was,
“responsible for some pretty
dramatic, pretty public mistakes.”
Now that was quite candid.
And I wonder what examples
you were thinking of when
you shared that message
internally with CDC staff.
It wasn't hard to find
headlines of places
where CDC was taking heat.
One of them, of course,
was the lab
and the early diagnostic
test that came out.
And others have just been
confusing and
complicated messages.
Great news this week.
The CDC announced that fully
vaccinated people no longer have
to wear masks
or socially distance,
except if you go to most places.
Early on, our guidance
was very technical.
We were not necessarily
accustomed to having
our guidance be a place
where every American
would click on CDC
and read our school guidance
or read our quarantine guidance.
But that's how it was
being utilized now.
So we had to rise
to the occasion.
So one of those components
was really delivering our science
in real time when we knew it.
And then the 2nd is
saying it in plain language.
What does this mean?
What are the things
that it doesn't say?
that it does say?
And what is still unknown?
Among the changes,
Dr. Walensky will require
all employees be ready to deploy
to combat health crises,
marking a drastic shift
from a volunteer system
the agency relied on to
staff its Covid-19 response.
It is difficult with
multiple responses,
to have the same people respond
again and again and again.
And so what we need to do
is to make sure that every
person in this agency actually
considers response as a
critical element of their job.
There's a number of activities
that we're doing now
to sort of move in that direction.
I think there's a lot of challenges
that we're overcoming.
We were very siloed
in the way we respond
to various threats
before Covid-19.
The level of the response
needed really required us to
work across the
agency to pull together.
What I wanted that
restructuring to reflect
is high visibility, accountability
within the agency and
what are those key places
that we really need
to be responsible.
So things like our laboratory,
our Office of Science,
our public health
infrastructure and workforce.
I really want to decrease
layers of reporting,
decrease the
bureaucracy, if you will.
We're in a BSL-4
laboratory training facility.
Biosafety level 4.
Yes. We train people
so that they can work safely
and effectively when
they're really dealing with
the most pathogenic agents
that we have, things
like smallpox, Ebola.
When we looked at what's
happened in the pandemic,
there were really 3 things
we want to do better.
The 1st is we can't have
a test that goes out
that doesn't have a thorough
enough quality review.
The 2nd thing, we need to get it
as fast as possible
to the private sector.
And the 3rd thing,
we want to make sure
we stay on top of
the best technologies,
because we would
like to have tests
like the tests that you
get in drugstores
but to be as accurate
as the PCR test.
I heard a lot of optimism
from CDC staff about their
plans to move forward.
But one potential
obstacle is Congress.
Funding is a place we've seen Congress reach a roadblock.
What kind of resources
will it take to execute
the strategy that you've laid out?
One of the challenges of CDC,
when I got here was that
we were working off a frail,
underfunded public health
infrastructure, not just the CDC,
but around the country.
There have been data that
have suggested that the workforce
the workforce is 80,000
public health workers in deficit.
Wow.
When you start with that
infrastructure and you
layer on top of it
a global pandemic
that affects 330 million Americans,
that affects
330 million Americans,
you have challenges
at the get go.
Moving Forward, in my mind
is really a lot about
what's the best,
most efficient way
that we can take the resources
that we have right now and
leverage them to do the best
that we can within CDC.
There will be areas and
places where we will ask
for additional resources in our
public health infrastructure,
in our data modernization efforts,
in our laboratory capacity.
And then there will be places
that we fully recognize
that we're going to need
congressional help
in order to be nimble.
I want to talk about
politics for a moment
because science
has become political.
I wonder what the toll of
that has been on the CDC.
Sometimes it's harder in a
politically charged environment,
but our job is to deliver
health in a bipartisan way.
I always go back to when
I'm standing in front of a patient,
they don't necessarily challenge
the reason that you're there.
They know that you're
there to care for them.
This agency perceives
the country as their patient.
So the most important thing
that we do is put our head down,
do the science, public health,
action-oriented work
to deliver health.
We're going to need
to demonstrate that
regardless of the political
powers that are out there.